los familiares de las víctimas buscan
respuestas por la vía legal treinta y
cinco de ellos representados en las más
recientes demandas lideradas por el
abogado anthony busby alegan que la
negligencia con la que se manejó el
evento culminó en la muerte de ocho
personas más de una docena demandas ya
han sido presentadas contra los
promotores del festival astro world en
houston texas el rapero travis scott y
las compañías black nation entertainment
inc y scoreboard son los principales
acusados
es evidente que el concierto se
planificó increíblemente mal
y no se tuvo en cuenta la seguridad de
estos jóvenes en el concierto que no
había ningún mecanismo de respuesta de
emergencia para ayudar a los que estaban
en una situación extrema
no había personal médico y suficiente
personal de seguridad había más gente de
la que debería haber estado allí los
fallecidos oscilan entre los 14 y 27
años y el propio scott se ofreció a
pagar por los gastos funerarios pero
para los familiares no es suficiente
estamos muy muy dolidos estamos de luto
vamos a quedarnos aquí y vamos a
conseguir justicia el jefe de la policía
de houston aseguró haberse reunido con
scott antes del trágico concierto del
viernes expresando las preocupaciones
por la seguridad del evento
el departamento de policía de houston
inició una investigación criminal con
detectives de homicidios y narcóticos
tras recibir informes que aseguran que
una persona del público estaba
inyectando drogas a los asistentes